I'm Greg I'm Morgan Morgan Han how to
some organ and Ashley is a youtube
channel Instagram when life hands you
Morgan and how to blondes make a write
with a number two on Instagram as well
hey Morgan hey Greg you we talked
earlier how we both grew up Catholic we
did transition Eduardo Cruz said to me
Eduardo yo Greg can you watch the
trailer for the crucifixion this movie
looks terrifying how he sounds that do
you know him
no ok the crucifixion here we go
why are you why are you scared I'm sorry
for the lighting being so dark one of my
lights broke and the natural lighting
outside is it's it's like hell's
freezing over right now so perfect time
for the crucifixion we did say good time
for these jokes
I never watch scary movies
get ready fibrous aroma third you were
convicted for the murder of it no no
[Music]
oh wow it's a true story during an
exorcism but being arrested in charge
now a possessed nun story it's another
chance for you to nail faith to the wall
I'm father Anton you mind if I ask you a
few questions
listen to this whatever was inside of
her was challenging me too
[Music]
there's nothing to talk about you see it
in sometimes hides and the governments
of the holy
you need protection whether you believe
it or not demons are real there is a
heaven and there is a hell
oh I can't cuz original to you if you
wanted to hear No
there are different stages to follow
[Music]
it's important to find out who they do
monies
[Music]
the elder sisters now in direct battle
with the demon
[Music]
oh my god ride stop it Oh a doll Oh God
Allah jump-scares in that one child's
play
I've never even seen I'm seen any of
them trailer the worst guys for seven
years
oh my goodness I did not hear about this
story I mean they were inside she's
doing right well it sounds like they
were trying to save her they had to kill
her because a demon possessed her but
the question is do we believe that new
bus non-catholics or whatever believe
that but I you know know I'm scared it's
scary and scared to think about MA hey
car stop scary basics is shot really
well there's some really creepy moments
with the crotch thing oh my god a bunch
of bugs around this China I've never
seen that especially in a trailer
opening so that was [ __ ] nuts
that was crazy and really surveying that
maybe scared me out the most out of
everything oh man I mean now you're
gonna think about that when you wake up
or when you have a blanket over you and
then you take it off because you sleep
without pants on when you might have a
bunch of bugs there well it might that's
what that's where the demons possessing
truth based off your hygiene see too
much of Ivy's vampire soda no and
néstor oh yeah good good call oh my god
but this this seems like such a
controversial piece of work here how do
you get away with making a movie like
this it's it's so heavy I mean I guess
it's heavily religious that's nice yeah
hint of religion like the power of
Christ compels you and you're like I
don't know like this is like really
involved in the church you know it's
more than just like oh there's priests
involved and then there's a demon
exorcism it's like no this is like the
[ __ ] Church you know and they're
taking a true story and they're
obviously tweaking some stuff I'm like
not everything plays out like a horror
movie in real life rule of three that
the jump scare happens you know but it
does look creepy it does look scary I
actually admire that it's like really
involved within the church actually cuz
that's that's a bold move yeah yes our
freedom that we have the poor lady who
they thought was possessed and they or
at least maybe and movie seems like it's
taking the route where she is possessed
yeah and they couldn't get it out of her
as a man who studies so many exorcisms
yeah they they nine out of ten they
succeed on a successful exorcism I mean
did they save Emily Rose no name now she
died that was part of the trial I guess
not so her answers are the men go away
they listen if you ever get possessed
just now I will always be there for you
[Music]
[Laughter]
I might here with a ladder see I think
if i kidnap it possessed woman that mean
waiting to kidnap you in a closet yeah
you know even though I don't consider
myself Catholic now because I grew up
Catholic this stuff freaks me out I
think it's real
yeah it's obsessive things like yeah I
beat that character in the movie
I don't believe in fairy tales no that's
stuff any more than that all the demon
stuff what's going on I do believe it
this stuff is shot really welded shot
really what like it looks it's like a
good looking film and like it's framing
something people see it be excited about
it well I will be at home watching The
Lion King or something joyful it won't
like it's not very joyful but what is it
around her crotch
I don't know hair but it's not her
it looks like a like ants that is like
[Laughter]
this is a lot of shots of things you
just hate I mean the needle in the eye I
know exactly shot just look at it enjoy
it enjoy it and now I wear contacts nope
I cannot even poke my eyes are you oh my
god it's like Rachel and Friends well
well thanks for a water for sending that
my way and reigniting my Catholic
nightmares hey you can subscribe to the
rejects
Morrigan but life hands you Morgan is on
Instagram and she's also how to's with
Morgan and Ashley on YouTube and how two
blonds make a ride on Instagram follow
her on everything